and back to back outs on eight pitches
for tyler wiley a seventh round draft
choice back in june of 2013 out of high
school
and their strike three tobias to retire
beside david bode checks in two runs
batted in last night
2-2 pitch
good looking
nasty pits taking a nosedive nothing
game and the batter now is nick
castellanos
slow breaking ball castianos waits on it
and drives it into left center field for
extra bases
and he goes standing up with a double he
had a whopping 58 of those a season ago
now it's josh van meter swinging a miss
on another changeup that's his first
strikeout here's aristidis aquino
a man at second no score two down
fastball ground ball toward third
juggled but recovered by bodhi the toss
across in plenty of time and the reds do
not score castillanos gets a double but
nothing else scoreless game third inning
jason kipnis will bat there it is
fly ball center field akiyama
no idea where it is
kittness around second on his way to
third
he's got a triple
we thought we would have trouble finding
the ball
doing the broadcast
remotely the reds outfielders had no
clue hey see this ball it's in shadow
and then into the bright sunlight and uh
akiyama you could tell by his body
language he had no idea cornermen in
they're back in the middle against
nicole horner a good contact guy in this
spot
smacks this one into right and the cubs
lead again one nothing
how good was that sat back on that
breaking pitch whacks it the other way
two down nobody on cubs lead one to
nothing in the third and here is shogo
akiyama
[Music]
popped into shadow center and it will be
schwarver
losing his glasses but he caught the
ball
in front of ian happ to help out alec
mills and that's an excellent play by
schwarber as i watch it again there's
the defensive gem of the night now men
at first and third and kepnes
is batting again
a base hit to right
hayward will score
bodhi stays at second it's two to
nothing
big night all ready for kipnis
that brings up nicole horner check swing
roller malley will throw to second throw
to first and that's a double play and
they badly deal to that castellano is
the only red with a base hit tonight
first with about a one step lead over
there is wink
that ball hit hard into right field
backing up his hayward it will fly out
of here the first home run is a red for
nicolas castellanos and ty sings up now
in 2-2 in the fourth what an excellent
at-bat for nick castiano's
i can hit now no doubt about it so
maya's at second base with two away
it'll bring up kyle schwarber a lefty
versus lefty matchup
schwarber lines this one into left for a
base hit
here comes the throw to the plate
safe it was close baez got in and the
cubs lead again three to two
little flipped the other way aquino gets
off a good strong throw here javi taking
that wide angle into home plate to get
that back corner just ahead of the tag
by cassalli two down in the inning for
casalli
cassalli drills one to deep short buy
his backhand throw to first and he nails
casalli another excellent play by baez
one knee on the ground made the
backhanded stop with his red glove
hopped up and fired a strike to first
to end at the end nico horner with a run
scoring single has also bounced into a
double play big at-bat in this game
minute second and third high fly ball
center field hayward ready to tag
akiyama makes the catch here comes the
runner the throw is late
it's four to two you know javi has
talked a lot about trying to have fun
plays with a lot of flair
just swung at a 3-0 pitch sends it high
and deep to right field castiano set the
wall it's gone
javi baez with an opposite field homer
so he beats garrett and it's five to two
there it is the big lift and separate
from baez now bodhi waiting for nate
jones
swinging a high fly ball right center
field will this one carry out of the
yard it's got a chance it's gone
home run david bodie opposite field
right center cubs lead six to two eight
towering blast
bodhi crunches this one
great swing of the bat by david
there's a high fly ball well hip deep
left field and cassalli is homered for
the second time this year and that makes
it a 6-3 ball game
one away baez the batter cubs lead 6-3
in the top of the ninth inning so he
will bat with a man in scoring position
and one out
two to baeza drive to center he thinks
he got it and he is right
eight to three
his first homer of the year came back in
the seventh inning
and it didn't take long for the second
home run for buy it now freddie galvez
i fly ball deep right field and this one
will fly out of here two-run home run
by freddie galvez
and that makes it an eight to five ball
game galvez his second home run of this
season and the 2-2 to casalli
smalling on and miss strike three and
the cubs win the ball game